so leaving harvard i built out another
robotics company
and that is a robotics company that is
really focused on
the mechanical engineering and materials
of the gripper
and that was in a case where the amazon
problem a variable size weight shape
needs to get into a box infinite number
of skews
for root it was the exact inverse
problem which is
these a tomato is a delicate object but
it's not like one tomato is going to be
the size of a grape and then one next to
it to basketball right like it is
reasonably regular you need to have a
lot of experience in how to grip and and
that's something i've built
over a long career in doing this but
really the new challenge was the
artificial intelligence and until
recently it just wasn't doable both the
the massive advances in convolutional
neural networks and their applications
to computer vision
that was enabling the fact explain that
for a second unpack that what does that
mean in plain english to a neophyte
the modern world of computer vision
can really is really robust in that
you're creating these training data sets
you're
taking photographs of an environment you
are annotating you're circling the
objects of interest let's say you're
looking for cars you're circling images
of cars and you're feeding those images
where a human said where the cars are
into a complex statistical model that
teaches
itself what are the fundamental
attributes of cars and if you
put unoccluded images of cars it's just
easy to see whole car
it will find whole cars if you add to
that data set semi-obstructed views of
cars
they'll get good and you'll start to
understand how to also find
semi-obstructed versions of cars
if you take a look at some of the older
versions of
of computer vision whereas really
top-down creation of the different
filters that found
objects they just would easily break
down
in practice in complex environments so
they were really good at
if i needed to pick an object off of a
conveyor
and put it in a box and it was a well
singulated object it had nothing else
around it it was up and it was up
against a simple background it was a
white conveyor
you could and maybe it had a logo on it
where you had the ability
to look for the lettering you could take
that previous generation of computer
vision
and make it work in that application but
you throw a
pile of those objects into a bin and
it's many different objects and suddenly
the environment is hyper complex and and
those those vision algorithms the older
ones would fall apart
the modern generation of computer vision
that everyone's talking about
is able to take on highly complex
real-world applications and it's quite
remarkable
i would say that the another major thing
that has changed
is being able to have computers
that you can use at the edge so when
you're in a farming environment
you're first of all usually far away
from wi-fi
you're far away from the it's not like
you're gonna plug into a wall jack right
you're often surrounded by plants which
have a way
all the water content in those plants
also have a way
of blocking signals so the concept of
like i'm gonna take an image
at the robot i'm going to pass it to a
computer in the cloud and i'm going to
run a model
that is not for the most part a
tractable solution
for real-time artificial intelligence
required for picking the fact that i can
buy
the system on module computers with
chips designed for running these models
and they barely consume any electricity
super important
for a mobile platform i just buy these
things they're cheap
and i can put them into my robotics
platform that's a complete game changer
it's the reason why you're seeing it's
one of the reasons why you're seeing
autonomous driving become ever more
practical application
of artificial intelligence
that is the reason why
we're seeing a lot of hardware being put
at the edge of compute platforms we had
a
company on the program that was building
cameras for checkout lists
of shopping and they put there are
people making cameras with
graphic cards in them or putting racks
in the back of
the stores so that they can do that
computing computer vision in real time
and that all comes from
gaming correct if the gaming cards had
not
been 60 frames 120 frames per second and
then increasing crazy resolution
we would have never had these nvidia
cards or whatever cards
to be able to do this correct it's funny
um because where i started to experience
those graphics cards was early in my
career when
at a point in life where i was very
misguided and i wanted to be an academic
and there's a lot of i was doing a lot
of spectroscopy
and protein biophysics and all of a
sudden
there were a couple of really brilliant
groups that realized you could start
running
a lot of hardcore physics on
playstations
and then you started slapping together a
bunch of playstations you had a super
computer
and it was earth shattering and that was
in my my old field a million years ago
that that same kind of aha moment that
it's a fundamentally different
kind of chip in the way it runs these
calculations in there
and the kinds of math that you do for
for artificial intelligence is really
well mapped to those chipsets it's it
just makes everything
move bleeding fast and now you have the
economic incentive of cryptocurrency and
bitcoin and hash
i is that compounding at another level
that people are buying all these cards
to do that
i love the fact that people are doing
all of these
custom chip projects and that we're
getting ever more specific
kinds of chips for running different
parts different kinds of
important calculations that you would
find on a robot but yeah the other
application you should talk about
as well being able to run that all at
the edge
with very little data passed along a
sparse amount of metadata to pass along
the cloud or pass along to a user it
just
it allows you to put these put these
algorithms
in places where they touch the real
world and solve dramatically
more interesting problems or at least
more interesting to me
every startup needs business insurance
and you should look no further
than my friends at in broker if you
don't have insurance
you failed one of the first steps of
being a great entrepreneur
in broker's technology saves you time
and money prices are up to
20 lower with better coverage than the
incumbents and you can go from sign up
to quote
and purchase in just 10 minutes i trust
me i've been
through this for three decades of
getting insurance i'm getting old here
folks
and in broker is quick easy and
affordable
and there's four types of insurance that
are critical in the startup space
i know these like the back of my hand
because i'm on the board of companies
and i see when things go wrong and i see
what the insurance can do
in terms of decision making cyber
insurance super important
unfortunately because things are getting
hacked constantly do you know insurance
that's if your directors and officers
board members your senior employees do
something dumb and you get sued
let's leave it at that and eno that
covers errors and omissions and that
will help you scale because any major
customer
will say do you have you know if you
want to close a deal and finally epl
employment practices liability this
covers harassment wrongful termination
and more
so to instantly buy custom built
insurance for startups go to
inbroker.com twist e m b
r o k e r dot com slash twist while
you're there you get an extra 10 off
if you use the offer code twist please
put in the offer code twist so they know
that i sent you
okay let's get back to this amazing
episode
you